even when you speed this logo up it
feels like forever maybe it is do I
exist here is still a page from a book
so was the ceremonial looking
decapitation really necessary in order
to steal the book you must first remove
the head of the librarian on overnight
duty on whatever knot you attack and you
must do so while he suspended six feet
in the air arms and legs played with two
axes all that culminating in the head
landing in ancient Lord du cow's
favorite dead pan bucket welcome to some
idiotic the first couple minutes of this
movie these guys come in murder the
bookkeeper and for what but they were
one page out of a book when they could
easily steal the whole thing they not
bring enough help kind of infuriates me
that this will be a big deal later in
2016 audiences were delighted to see
inception - in theatres which they
weirdly called dr. strange I mean
strangely called dr. strange like Harry
Potter this movie will never stop to
explain what the motions really do or
whose motion should be out wings these
hologram blades do hologram damage to
the bad guys why exactly are these guys
allowed but just leave again can't you
put them in an interdimensional jail or
something they killed your bookkeeper
she's definitely visible to this lady on
the right so it gives you some rules
maybe I bet you're gonna tell me that
will come later but I have my doubts oh
gee hot rich I feel so good man charted
in 1978 the album is released in
December of 1977 brilliant cocky
charming guy who gets deeply injured
then overcomes that injury to become
hero
that's so starkly familiar why are they
alright Bruce Wayne also I don't care
how good a surgeon he is I don't want my
surgeon playing musical trivia with the
nurses during my surgery shows a
detachment from reality that suggests
I'll lose my life and he won't lose any
sleep is it yes W for the record doctors
of the world GSW literally has two more
syllables than the phrase it stands for
gunshot wound
just sayin yelling don't seem very smart
with this particular abbreviation this
is brain surgery but neither of them are
wearing a mask but in that first surgery
scene everyone in the goddamn room had a
mask on is it the movie or the hospital
that's playing fast and loose with the
medical rules now they put masks on
the wrists over your watch okay aside
from further humiliating the CR dr.
Ghana the scene exists to show how good
strangers hearing is I guess but if
hearing or important during surgery
blasting the hips of the 70s would be
grounds for malpractice suit
movie wants to have its cake and eat it
and have a portrait of the cake made and
then eat that
humiliate him in front of everyone after
City's patient either GE has a point
he according to the Hippocratic oath
does not yeah you're right in ER we're
only saving live movie not only utterly
waste rachel mcadams that uses her best
acting on a medical walk and talk i got
a strange talk
oh well good I'm glad something's named
after me this movie schools Jurassic
world on how to write we used to date
sexual tension dialogue well still being
super cliche and predictable we use
today dialogue point is both movies did
it poorly but Jurassic world did it even
more report I should have to explain
this goddamn I do love the New York
scale is that the King Avengers bluej
building King hell listen if you have a
watch drawer if your watches inside said
walk drawers are all spinning as though
each is trying to get your attention to
get you to pick them your Vayner than
whoever Carly Simon wrote you're so vain
about this watch suggest it's February
around 2 p.m. even though there's no
snow anywhere in this movie and a
serious shortage of winter coats hats
and gloves by outdoor pedestrians by the
way where is this out in the middle of
nowhere a mountainous region close to
New York City
you drive upstate no answering phone
calls using your finger while driving at
high speed on this road this guy's
driving 80 miles an hour on a curvy road
in the mountains passing people and
clear no pass zones and he still looks
at the x-ray how did crashing not happen
well before this also he survives this
so he crashed way too outside the city
in the mountains but somehow his
downtown New York City Hospital he works
at was still the closest hospital or
else they flew way out of their way to
take him where he wanted to go and he
was able to tell them where he wanted to
go
no one could try ranee shoo brain and I
drove super fast and distracted and blew
off equipment should be happy to be
alive but still is all your fault
strange asked his physical therapist
sarcastically if he's ever known anyone
to have this much nerve damage yet still
recover and dude says yes and tells him
about Benjamin Bratt and miracle and a
half that the only dude to do this
because he went to the temple of
whatever somehow had the same physical
therapist a strange movie should have
just had the temple order recruits ass
this oh yeah there was this one guy but
was kind of insulting actually no one
would be seated during the doctor
strange wants to shave but decides not
to shave see I'm not getting any better
but still as sad as that is you drove
yourself off a cliff by driving like an
asshole late at night in the mountains
I mean exactly how much empathy is this
movie expecting me to have with this
entitled sourpuss there are other things
that can give your life meaning
why you there relationship survives this
ha
France Christine we were barely lovers
before turning this movie into a
possible inception sequel it was briefly
considered for a season four episode of
Grey's Anatomy
so Doctor Strange went looking for
Pangborn and movie skips over the part
where strange was able to track him to
this afternoon pickup basketball game
that is apparently inside a cage
underneath an interstate or some point
in his movie skips over some impossible
detective work to avoid showing how
impossible it was in case you confused
it with Katmandu génifique converse on I
can see some sort of lucky break like
this happening but what Mordo doing here
in the marketplace today he's just
standing around hoping to hear someone
ask about a place where he works I guess
white guy in Katmandu confronted by
three attackers who punches one of them
with his recently surgically
reconstructed hand forget everything you
think you know I'd like to forget this
line of dialogue since it appears in
roughly one of every six movies Thank
You ancient one for seeing you're very
welcome
why the could you go through all this
just to make a random stranger think
someone else was the ancient one if you
were just going to introduce yourself
immediately anyway just the strange
doctor actually
well no not anymore surely isn't that
why you're here well no actually he's
probably still a doctor by degree and
experience
it's just his hands don't work anymore
I'm quite sure he came here to get his
hands working again not to become a
doctor again since that label surely
never left also does this mystical come
through school accept all comers because
he got this place's name from a dude
that actually rejected their philosophy
and left and he just showed up on the
doorstep and yet they took him in and
deemed him worthy of training because
why again they just trained anyone that
shows up when I started getting here
one-way ticket and you're talking to me
about healing through belief isn't that
exactly what penguin told strange before
we made this trip but getting his mind
right is how he got his body to heal
hell let's replay that theme my mind was
elevated and my spirit deep in somehow
the body healed hell you weren't even
skeptical you filled in the blanks on
your own oh cool a butterfly but even in
this astral dimension how does the
butterfly live in space or am I missing
the point I'm probably missing the point
oh my I just realized how Marvel intends
to keep its MCU properties going
perpetually using these Doctor Strange
infinite universes and that's bad it
opens the door to the marvel cinematic
multiverse to pad the runtime the
ancient ones compound goes on Fight Club
for a few minutes i Silius still has the
stolen pages if he deciphers them he
could bring ruin upon us all how long do
you think it'll take it he took that
ages ago movie time are you all just
hoping he has a super slow translator or
something or what's this I'm not sure
the Wi-Fi possibly uh-huh that's funny
but why would you give him a card with a
strange word on it and not tell him it's
the Wi-Fi password as soon as you give
it to him also that password is super
hackable flash of the mystic arts is as
old civilization that sentence literally
means nothing I like it from here to
there how did you get to reattach seven
nerves and studying practice year's
event the ancient one suggests it will
take years years of study and practice
for strange to master this art but the
movie will suggest he does it in mere
months because the movie is cheating why
do you wait so long to do this ritual
you still that book way back in the
first scene and even though we don't
technically know when that happened the
timeline it suggested it was before all
the doctor strange habit which means
this guy broke in killed fools stole the
book then took what months to do
anything else after that which is weird
right
Nach Nicholson said I'll take this rule
but only if I can have something up with
my eyes because he Nouriel is a
tremendous hit basically because of the
I think they control it by surrendering
control it doesn't make you must not
have seen the Matrix movies or every
pottery or Star Wars I just don't
understand how you can be the chief
librarian of a magic training complex
and this is something that any asshole
can do if they feel like it why aren't
there any other defensive measures in
this place also somebody doesn't hear
anything going on because they're
wearing headphones cliche if I told you
everything else that you don't already
know you'd run from here in terror what
every officiant should say to every
groom in every wedding ever when you
first came to life he's lost everyone he
ever loved
by its position it's weirder but he gets
full internet access in the training
dojo or the fact that he sends emails
with the largest font imaginable the
director said let's have your character
eat an apple no make it look like even
more of an asshole heroes like the
Avengers protect the world from physical
dangers not a Marvel movie if we don't
spend a lot of time talking about other
Marvel movie
the sorceress safeguarded against or
mystical threads hmm what can't you also
use your powers to protect it from
physical dangers again where were you
during all the times the world was until
danger you don't think they could have
used some magic outside of Scarlet Witch
a being of infinite power and less
hunker quest to invade every universe
and he hungers for us most of all but
somehow this being of infinite power
can't crack sanctum magic okay this
movie just showed us doors that
transport them from their dojo to one of
the three sanctums on earth now inside
one of those sanctum strange find some
more instant transport doors all of
which it's kooky to me since we already
saw that they can use a glowy horn
spells they need to transport so why do
they need all the magic doors the master
of the sanctum shows up to defend it
just as the bad guy appears but where
was he while strange was wandering
around this joint literally yelling
hello also I mean they place one guy in
charge to guard all this stuff and then
they wonder why it fails these guys
aren't particularly clever
pan-dimensional beings they killed a
master this place immediately with a
sword fight but strange it was super
experienced they take a bunch of time
just to put it why it doesn't feel like
this fight should be in any way close I
know that strange has learned a lot a
short amount of time this guy's been
doing it for years should be able to see
things differently to the point strange
shouldn't even be able to escape during
this fight once again people with
superpowers end up making this a fist
fight with a few kicks run it man is he
coming a few coming the one-man e---coli
butchered that rat a con quote
[Laughter]
wait a minute this is movie saying she
can't see the two astral projections
fighting so why could she clearly see
strange when he was helping her operate
on it this is known as playing fast and
loose with the rules also I kind of find
it hard to believe that the physical
structure of this hospital has anything
to do with the physics of these astral
projections why are they slamming
against walls when they should just be
going through everything so physical
voltage translates directly to ask for
projection strength for some reason
honestly this might be the most baffling
thing in this movie
I mean King exploded that guy's ghost
and it caused the real world bad guy's
forehead to smolder that's bonkers they
broke up I made tons of noise during
that revived him so his ghost can
electrocute another ghost stuff but
still all alone and I'm bothered in a
New York City Hospital operating room
and I talked to someone called the
ancient one and they joined a cop wait a
minute we can't be this dismissive about
strange when you just saw him as an
astral projection a minute ago he can't
suddenly turn into Dana Scully after you
bore witness to King magic during the
entire time strange was on the operating
table and beating up a low-rent magic
henchman nobody walked into this closet
and noticed a portal to another world
also the holy thing is indefinite he has
to manually shut it down why don't the
movie explain this better when they
spent about 15 minutes on this wait he
didn't do anything to shut it down he
just went through it and it shut down
like it's some kind of round-trip portal
when he clearly used a one-way portal
back to Cal Meritage from Mount Everest
earlier and that portal isn't still open
at least I think it isn't right right
and would make you in another comment
about how wasted Rachel McAdams is in
this movie but instead I'm compelled to
talk about the storeroom this is a
supply closet look how big it is look at
how much square footage is utterly being
wasted here how does this hospital not
have more storage devoted to toilet
paper you defended the New York sanctum
from attack through sheer ping luck what
is he talking about I'm talking about
her long life the source of her
immortality she draws power from the
dark dimension to stay alive you mean
he's never once wondered why the ancient
one has lived so long the connection to
the doctor medicine makes them more
powerful in the mirror dimension they
can't affect the real world but they can
still tell that and why didn't Casillas
do this himself earlier unless you're
telling me that he doesn't have the
power to make a mirror dimension which I
highly doubt you know what I wish I wish
these Stan Lee cameo somehow told a
story over the course of many movies
like if you piece them together it would
be something mind-blowing instead they
continue their pointlessness just so you
marvel fanboy can say oh look there's
Stan Lee look I know it's the mirror
dimension which the movie
defined as basically literally anything
goes but he's folding the city
supposedly but the park top left he's
folding in is actually the same exact
mirror opposite of the cityscape that
he's folding it into here here here here
these are all the same buildings he
somehow doubled the city upside down and
movie wants me to act like he bent
Manhattan in half or some and here movie
is doubling down on its lie as every
building top or bottom appears different
than the building it's about to impact
suggesting this is literally a city fold
and not an upside down city clone while
I give the movie points for visual
ingenuity they've basically created a
finale fight where literally anything
can happen which is the biggest cheat of
all also it's important to note the
magic cloak does virtually nothing to
help save strangers life during the
sequence despite its obvious ability to
do so if it would I think the mirror
dimension is one big middle finger to
cinemasins
well she certainly waited long enough to
make an appearance Jesus lady what were
you doing in the last 15 minutes
meditating strange realizes who's
shaking hands are back and finally
concedes to the inferior surgeon he
hated earlier this is supposed to show
growth but honestly if his hands weren't
shaking he'd still have insisted on
doing the surgery himself he has not
grown at all really see this time when
strange brought in an emergency surgery
patient at the hospital responded unlike
last time when he and Christine
basically had an unchaperoned picnic
date in the operating room okay I feel
like I'm getting this movie more sins
removed than I should but hot Jesus at
slow-motion lightning is just the
coolest freakin touch in this astral
projection conversation what was the
cloak doing during that entire emotional
relationship conversation with Christine
just hanging back giving strange some
space I'm guessing the filmmakers just
wanted a cool draw my cloak to me shot
and didn't give any more talk to it
there's a web and wisely seems like
these guys have multiple warriors who
can protect a sanctum so why did the
Manhattan branch employ one dude on the
wrong side of history well or maybe dare
I say it the long side of history I'll
give myself five cents for that don't
mom always come and right on cue the
main bad guys just happened to be
walking down this very street for some
reason in the end is this any different
from Superman flying around the world a
reverse time yes yes it is but I still
want to complain about it only because
there are supposed to be consequences to
using this power and apparently there
are none so with everything going in
Reverse is there any real danger here
isn't this like just rewinding an old
VHS tape can you actually physically be
in the way of something that already
happened did I just write that since
there are so many space patties in these
Marvel movies now like totally expect
Thanos to show up during this
confrontation with a completely
different space patty
I've come to bargain and this is what we
come to see in movies completely
creative humorous new way to fight the
bad guy
strange takes a fairly innocuous warning
about time powers from earlier in the
movie and turns it into pure gold I'm
removing two sins for this great scene
one of the more memorable of 2016 in
case you confused it for now usually has
something to say on shots like this we
could have seen this in the Doctor
Strange sequel ring I don't know this
end credits scene thing has its purpose
for sure get you excited about the next
movie at the salesmanship I just don't
know the purpose of getting excited
about a movie that won't come out for
hell even Marvel doesn't know when
that's happening so continuing with
movie theater ushers Marvel by God you
need to continue this silly step add the
bank account which is 80 percent spider
webs at this point you make so few
dollars
[Music]
[Applause]
Simo protect would you protect them how
to reprogram nerve cells to self-heal
you think that's air you're breathing
fuckin head
[Music]
[Applause]